hi thank you all this is marahar futado
i'm going to do a brief presentation on
the south kobe 2 related workflow and
solutions from therma fisher we'll be
talking mainly about detection systems
and genotyping and a few other topics
so in the next slide what you'll see is
i'm going to start off
giving a background on sarskv to
some information about how thermal
pressure is enabling research
will give you an overview of diagnostic
solutions eua approved formats
overview of some of our audio research
formats
we'll talk a little bit about sarskovito
mutations and variants and why it's
important to pick them up
a couple of slides on some environmental
testing and end with our service and
support resources so with that
the next slide is the background
so essentially uh as you all know the
sars outbreak
has had a global impact what you see on
this slide is a who update
of the global
spread of the virus as of june 4th 2020
you will see the countries continents
listed and the number of people who have
been
confirmed infected number of deaths and
overall this has been a very stressful
solution
for people all over the world the next
slide you have a brief overview of
coronaviruses so in the red boxes here
you will see one two three four
coronaviruses that
do infect humans they do not cause major
disease more like a common cold but then
in two thousand and one we saw the first
sarcoid
pathogenic strain come up which caused a
lot of mortality then in 2012 we had the
murder scoe which is transmitted through
camels had a higher mortality rate and
then you have the current pandemic
with the sars kobe 2
19 and so that's still ongoing so these
viruses have been with us for many years
as you can see the date here the
earliest discoveries
translate back to 1960
they are found in domestic and wild
animals so they are
among us in the populations
the life cycle for this virus is
depicted in here it's a
enveloped virus and you see the spike
protein on top of it enters into the
cell it's a single stranded positive
stranded virus it makes a double
stranded form of the virus it replicates
in some vesicles in here and then
ultimately migrates out through the
endoplasmic reticulum and you get new
virus particles coming out here what you
see on the right is a picture of these
virus vesicles where within which the
virus replicates and and the green
spaghetti-like things that you see are
the wires replicating in there
so let's go to how thermo fisher is
enabling sars kovi to research
as you know we are a global company the
number of brands that fall under thermo
fisher including applied biosystems
fisher and a couple of testing labs
our mission is to enable our customers
to make the world healthier cleaner and
safer
we
work on our industry leading scale
integrated connected reach
expanding global throughputs
and we have a global footprint
we have unmatched capabilities in terms
of generating research
and diagnostic products we also have
fairly comprehensive
services offerings
so the next slide you can go into that
in a little more detail
where as you'll see
we
have
material that we produce for protection
which is ppe and
related
materials that gloves and masks that
customers use on the analysis side we
have
leading generic and cellular analysis
platforms that are being used for
vaccine production gene therapy and
many other applications what we'll be
talking about today mostly is detection
which is
largely using the qpcr and some other
technologies for water detection and
also for genotyping as well as
sequencing the virus so that's going to
be the focus today then we also have
support for customers
who produce vaccine candidates and other
clinical trial logistics
we have responded in the past to many
pandemics and epidemics
the earliest one is anthrax in
somewhere around 2002 sars followed by a
number of other outbreaks around the
world so we do participate in
detection tests and other
applications in these disease areas
in the next slide we do have a global
health program
where we try to support
countries that are in the low to medium
income range we have agreements with
governments in many countries we are a
global health stakeholder and as you can
see
we have a single stop shopping
site for a lot of products that can be
used
for qpcr immunoassays microarray
sequencing and we have a large footprint
there
we focus on infectious disease
outbreaks oncology animal health and
environmental testing
so people have used
formats for all of these experiments
you see on the next slide
is some a view of our genetic testing
platforms
so we do
have a huge footprint in the qpcr area
for real-time analysis
this is our flagship products that
go on this system that can be used for
detection of the virus on the second
slot here you see that we have essays
that are called
discrimination pcr formats which can be
used for genotyping and variant
detection
more recently
we acquired a company called mesa and we
have a product now
called acura that is rapid testing where
you get a result within about 30 minutes
we have the ion tower platforms that are
used for ngs extensively we have the
triangle sequencing formats that have
been around for a couple of decades
still being used and then we have the
microarray platforms for doing
research on sarsko v2 and other
other diseases
in terms of covert testing solutions
specifically we do have eua approval for
a few kits and the first one that got
approval was the sars kobe 2 the kovid
19 combo kit and the kovite 19 advance
kit both of these
target three regions so there is one
essay in the orf region
one in the s region and one in the n
region so having multiple targets
helps make the sab more mutation
resistant so if you have mutations that
prevent one of the essays from working
the other two are in place
we
we have the capability to
also include a process control in there
we have multi-parametric analysis to
optimize the essays before we
commercialize them we do the test essays
for the
robustness stability failure modes and
then take it through eua or civd
approvals as required
so we're pretty
rigorous in our essay development
process
what you see in here is the intended use
for the backpack kit and the advanced
kits so in generally the qualitative
detection essays for new nucleic acids
related to sarcoido and the sample types
are in bold here nasopharyngeal
oropharyngeal swabs and
aspirates and bao or bronchial
all of them are approved for this
particular kit and they run on our
instruments listed below you see the con
studio here
the 7500s and the con studio 7 all of
them can be deployed to test this essay
on the next slide what you'll see is a
general workflow
so
we have an initial rna extraction on one
of our platforms referred to as the king
fissure
and that gives you nucleic acid
the nucleic acid is then used to set up
an rt reaction reverse transcriptase pcr
reaction which is done on our applied
biosystems
on the instruments
the data is interpreted by the kovind 19
interpretive software
and then you get a review of the
controls and then after that you get a
result that tells you
which of these channels is which of
these detectors is positive and you get
a positive negative results that's
reported out
we you do have the ability to get ct
values which can be obtained from the
instrument and usually the ct is an
indication of the cycle number when the
fluorescence
crosses the threshold
in a general sense the ct values are
somewhat proportional to the amount of
virus
the
other instrument i mentioned here is a
rapid pcr platform
called the acura this is a point of care
testing system
the company previously had 510k cleared
products for flow a b rsv and strep a
they now have an eoa for the sarsko v2
which can be used
the swabs are collected they go into a
collection media
and some of that is loaded onto the
instrument and you run it
and within about 30 minutes
and three simple steps you get a result
the read
reader is a lateral flow
unit and so you have some
readout in terms of certain lines on the
lateral flow instrument that correspond
to the control
and a positive line for
indicating presence of the virus
this has been
will
considerably improve the turnaround time
and speed things up so if i go to the
next slide then we want to talk about
the other kit that we recently got an
eoa approval for in a couple of months
ago
this is the version 2 of our combo kit
and one of the things we did here is to
increase the confidence in the results
in this particular case we have about
eight
targets within the essay
three of them uh
i mean
in three regions the rf1a the rf1b and
the n-genes and this compensates for any
new emerging sas virus mutations so
having degeneracy the number of targets
makes the essay extremely robust it's
very sensitive the
limit of detection is around 75 gc's per
amount it's more sensitive than the
version one that we had and it's
affordable and scalable
and easily added onto your testing menu
on the same instruments that i mentioned
before
the other part where we work is in
surveillance these are reo products
and they can be used to detect variants
so one workflow that we generally talk
about is detection and identification of
source coverage variants so if you have
a positive sample
in an initial screening test if the
sample comes up positive
then it can go in for variance screening
which can be done
by using genotyping assays
or
by amplicon based sequencing on a single
instrument
you can also use the ion tolerance to
get complete viral characterization so
this sequence all of the positive
samples can be sequenced and in general
gives you a good result in terms of
getting your entire
the plate classification
so workflow as we see it in the field
is twofold there is one arm which is
largely diagnostic testing
where you have the qpcr essays serology
essays part of care
and they go through
regulatory requirements clear cap
requirements and you get a result that
goes back to the
lab director and satisfies the patient
needs on the other side we also see a
need
for public health pipelines where
this data can go into a database
and inform public health in terms of
how to go about
managing the epidemic pandemic control
epidemiology data integration and this
is something we have seen
with
especially in the uk with public health
england and more recently with the cdc
here as well there's a lot of effort in
trying to
ensure that you're tracking all of the
variants that come through and the
methods used are qpcr genotyping
sanger sequencing and other methods and
we play in all of those spaces
in terms of genomic surveillance we do
have multiple options so one option is
to just sequence the entire virus which
can be done on the ion tolerance system
as i mentioned the option the other
option is to go through an rt pcr step
sequence samples that have
characteristic mutations of interest
so
you may take a subset of what comes out
of this and sequence it and additionally
most countries would also sequence five
to ten percent of all viruses just to
have a full handle on the entire
mutation spectrum of virus of variants
that are floating around there in terms
of a laboratory workflow the patient
sample comes in it could be
nasopharyngeal swab saliva
goes through a
extraction system on a kingfisher
then pcr the results go to the lab
director you get either negatives or
positives the patient's positive one
option is to go through
the genotyping format
where you can get
you can get results in terms of genotype
positives some countries are genotyping
50 to 100 percent of all of the way all
the samples that they have and this in
turn can
read inform
what needs to be sequenced so if you
find some new variants or some
variant of concern a variant of variant
under investigation as defined by who
those could go into sequencing you could
also have a subset of subpositives going
directly into sequencing so all of this
is enabled in a single lab and we have
instrumentation to support all of these
workflows
on the genotyping side
what you see here is a description of
the genotyping assay
so what we have here
in this picture in here is we have two
probes one binding to
the
allele one or the wild type if you wish
to call it that the other binding to the
mutant are really due
and
the signal generated from these two
probes is put on a cluster plot where
you'll see clusters in one end
corresponding to earlier one and
clusters of the other axis that
corresponds where we do so these essays
have been designed
and commercialized as snip essays they
run on the
you know routine track pacma the pcr
instruments with a slightly different
software that has to be used
so this is
used
in screening and testing for mutations
in a large number of samples we have
software that deals with this
and
most of this you'll find this on our
website so if i go to the next slide so
you'll see here are the mutation panels
the what we call premier essays are the
ones that are that are on stock
so these are the ones that are most
widely used by a customer base and they
can detect all of these who variants
listed in here
as you'll see
with time we have more and more variants
and as they increase we come up with
essays to meet
meet the needs for detecting all of
these variants in total we have about 52
essays online what you're seeing here is
the ones that are most frequently used
and on the next slide you'll see other
ones that are more custom essays and
used to a lesser extent but nevertheless
useful in different regions of the world
for identifying
uh what variance are in circulation
a little bit more about these variants
as you'll see the who and the
cdc and publication
england have lists where they classify
these as variants of concern
and i am not going to read through this
but it's on public websites where they
have several variants that are cropping
up now now each of them
have their own characteristics some of
them have mutations that due to which
they can escape
vaccines are not neutralized properly by
vaccines and you can see that
you can hear that more and more in the
news like especially with the delta
variant that's going around in the u.s
right now
so with these
variants there's been a number of
studies
where they have shown
the effects of these mutations on
the ability of vaccines to neutralize
these variants so what you see
in box b is neutralization of b117 and
on box d is neutralization of the south
african variant b
1.351
and as you'll see the
the antibodies produced in response to
the mrna 1273
vaccine from pfizer does neutralize the
b117 very well there's only a 1.2 fold
reduction which is a very small
reduction in terms of neutralization
capability
however when you go to the b135 one you
do see that there's a greater reduction
about 6.4 x these antibodies are able to
neutralize still neutralize
many of these viruses but
reduced
capability and this is more reduced when
it comes to the delta strains and as
you'll see now the response to this has
been that very soon we probably will
need boosted doses to boost up our
immunity
varying testing has been going on in
europe and there are recommendations
here from
the european cdc
for surveillance
surveillance of variance many countries
in the eu
are using our essays to try and figure
out what the responses and what the
spread of the viruses and a lot of them
by using this for
controlling the pandemic they do test
visitors who come into the country if
they're carrying deleterious variants
they can isolate them
and keep them in quarantine so this is
helping them track and
uh track and test and isolate people who
are being infected a good example of
this is the uk as you see on the
and the graph on the left
the the curve that you see in blue to
the extreme left of this
this graph is the one showing the
increase in delta variance in the uk
so the uk has been using a panel of
mutations from
what we supply so it's listed out here
on the buffs
on the right
so we have mutations for n501y the e484k
the k the the
k417
the k417t
and more recently your p681r
is there because of the delta variant so
they started off initially using
four of the mutations and somewhere in
may they introduced the p
681r to specifically pick up
the delta variance so this
is being actively used in the uk to
track these variants
and
the healthcare system there does use the
data to intervene in terms of
whatever is required for pandemic
containment and isolation so that's been
going on there and the next slide here a
little bit more detail on this so the
public health england started using this
more extensively to track the rapid
emergence of the delta variants
so as you'll see
on this slide
in the beginning they were using largely
sequencing and somewhere around the 11th
of may they started introducing i'm
sorry on 29th march they started testing
the mutation panels on may 11th they
introduced the new 681 rsh specifically
for the delta variant
and
and they have been converting a lot of
testing from
from ngs though they do still continue
to
sequence these viruses as well so as you
see in this graph below the dark blue
bars that you see
are what results they have with
sequencing this is waiting late in may
and the light blue bars are sequencing
our data got from genotyping and as you
can see
the genotyping results are available to
them in about 12 odds 12 to 18 hours
and so you'll see the sequencing part of
it is just catching up it takes them a
week or nine days to get sequencing
results back so using the genotyping for
formats gives them
faster access to what variants are
circulating in comparison they they
looked at the sequencing data and the
genotype typing data
and as of june what they're seeing is 99
of what's positive by genotyping is also
positive by sequencing so very high
concordance between the two platforms so
they have been using this
fairly extensively to be able to track
down
variants
what do you see on the next slide is
just a little bit of data in here so if
you have if you're testing this is data
from
essays looking at e484k and the division
6970
with genotyping essays so if you look at
it
the variant
comes up in one axis of the cluster plot
the wild type is on on the other axis
the software takes the fluorescence
coming out of the fam probe and the wave
probe and then plots these cluster plots
where what you're actually plotting is
the ratio of the fluorescence from the
two dyes
so
variance cluster here in blue and the y
type thruster the bottom here on the
x-axis
in red and so this can be used very
effectively what you see on the left is
the
the data for the e484k and on the other
right side you see the data for
for the 6970 deletion
and these data sets are from
all of inquest in stockholm sweden
which is many european countries are
using this test
and the next slide you'll see that
the reason for this gradient screening
is there are implications
medical implications related to the
presence of stars going to
variance some of them have
higher capability to transmit from
humans to humans
some
of them may change disease severity
some of them may lose susceptibility to
treatment like monoclonal antibodies
some of them evade
immunity controlled by vaccines and then
some of them may result in an impact on
diagnostic stress if the mutations
happen to be under the primers of probes
for a particular test so for these
reasons these variants are continuously
tracked and we do supply the agencies
with
regular updates on impact on any of our
essays as well as the using it for
tracking
individuals who
may harbor these variants
so complementary to genotyping is ngs
and other sequencing systems so what you
see here on the left is our ion gene
studio s5 series so this instrument has
two modules in there and then you have a
sample prep module and a sequencing
module
so this is a little bit more labor
intensive in terms of
getting the library construction and
other
other setups done on the right you see
the new genexis integrated sequencer
this is almost hands off and
highly automated and you can get a
result in about
in about nine to ten hours
or so
extensively used in biological research
for sars kobe 2 we can go with water
loads as low as 20 copies in the tube
uh we can confirm individual amplicons
by sanger sequencing if required
so this is being used extensively as
well for reporting into
the databases that you see here so the
genomic surveillance data with the ion
starscore we choose system it's got
software that lets you
plug into
different databases and also view the
data in
in reference to a reference sequence and
identify snips and variants
the data coming out of
the system can be uploaded into these
different databases that you see here it
also goes into the main
gca database into the ncbi and also
used by nextrain for global surveillance
to track
variance it's a very useful platform
and
used worldwide in many countries
so an example of this in
japan
so there is a traveler who
came in from brazil
on day one he was tested at the airport
he came up negative a few days later he
was hospitalized and tested positive
facade score we do within 24 hours they
were able to sequence the individual and
identify the variant as a p1 variant
which was new to japan so that helped
them
implement most most stringent
controls to prevent additional
transmission of this variant to other
individuals like quarantining this
particular individual
so this is just one example of how the
various sequencing methods and the
genotyping methods can be used to
contain the spread of variance and the
pandemic
on this slide you see our sanger
sequencing instruments these can be used
for single amplicon sequencing they are
also used through a couple of
collaborations in south africa where
they use this extensively for sequencing
the s gene
uh they do
provide mutation detection
and can also be used for other
applications so
one other thing that thermo fisher has
come up with more recently
is something called environmental
testing
and this is an instrument as you can see
on the next slide
so there is a air collection device that
collects air continuously and you can
see it may be collecting air for two
two hours to 12 hours or more
the air goes through a filter which is
in a cartridge in the second part of the
figure you can see the cartridge in here
so this cartridge will trap all viruses
not just sarskv2 it could also trap
fluid flow b rsv or other viruses the
cartridge can be tested in the in the
collection center itself or it could be
sent out and tested with one of the
essays to pick up the wires it could be
sequenced as well you can do all of it
the material is in here
you have to extract the
material from the cartridge which is a
simple process and it can go through
all the workflows that i showed you
earlier with a rapid testing or any
other format you want or sequencing to
get information so the application for
this is that if you have a hospital
and you try to establish a covet-free
zone and you have another another area
that's
harboring covet patients it's useful to
have this system in certain areas to
make sure
that there's no coverage in circulation
in the particular
in the particular region of the hospital
it can also be used in
industry or in schools to monitor the
environment so this is something we
launched recently
and
we are still working on getting all the
essays to work with post collections so
that's a
really good application that would be
useful
in many settings
and lastly i wanted to touch upon
service and support resources within
within thermo fisher
and we have a global sales and support
system we have
over one million customer interactions
annually
uh
you can see we have a lot of field
applications specialists
we
have service engineers
and a whole service organization that's
well set up to
support any needs in any country across
the world
field application specialist it's a
global scale effort and it has unmatched
depth so
we do have a service program called
platinum
it's 98
uptime guarantee to get total support
meets all the pandemic developments your
qualification services
it helped meet
regulatory requirements in different
countries so we will help you with some
of that priority technical support 365
days 24 7
including weekends
rapid response on site so guaranteed
engineer next blizzard's day if the
instrument goes down or you have any
issues of that kind
fas training
you can have remote training with fas
consultation they'll walk you through
the workflow
and the data analysis so you can
get up to speed rapidly or train new
technicians who come into the lab your
comprehensive repair coverage to
you know you can avoid
extended down times using the support
and then we have digital remote support
with on-demand tools that capabilities
that can be used
to help our customers and so with that i
think i'm at the end of my presentation
so in summary uh
what we try to go through is that the
global pandemic due to sars
obviously has infected millions of
people around the world and resulted in
many diets
additional concern has been the
emergence of variants across the globe
that have increased transmissibility
potentially increased disease severity
and the possibility that they may escape
neutralization by antibodies and you can
see the government's reacting nowadays
with suggestions of having boosted doses
in place
so garments pharmaceutical companies
diagnostics and
companies have all tried to rise to the
challenge to contain this pandemic by
using large-scale testing
test and trace plants like the one i
mentioned in the uk and in japan with
surveillance of genetic variants
thermo fisher specifically enabled the
use of qpcr platforms
point of care systems uh genotyping
offerings syringes angle sequencing
platforms for detection and genotyping
of the viruses we are we also introduced
antibody based testing solutions which i
didn't talk about but it is something
else we have in our portfolio system to
monitor the virus in the air which i
showed a couple of slides we also have
projects for wastewater testing and
testing for virus in the environment as
whole
they also work to enable sample
collection and vaccine production
efforts with various vaccine
manufacturers and other companies
so with that i'm going to conclude and
say thank you and for more information
please go to the thermofisher
website listed in here and you'll find a
lot more information on
you know the tests and materials
available for pandemic control so thank
you and i will end with that